good morning
millennials welcome back to the morning
toast happy friday you guys we made it
it's so beautiful to be at the tail end
of the week we have alarm free living
right ahead of us we've got ben on the
toast today hey ben how you doing i'm
doing great jackie how are you i'm doing
good i mean you know we're on day two
out of three of the ones takeover i
think it's going really well i think
people are really enjoying it i'm
enjoying it are you enjoying yourself i
yes this is it's wonderful i do have a
comment though on you said it's friday
yay like days of uh no alarms i've
started to think you know we're
celebrating fridays
only to have another week yet again next
week doesn't it kind of seem like we're
caught in a bit of a rat race it's true
we're going to kind of seem like we're
celebrating to be sad to celebrate the
sad to celebrate we're on this hamster
wheel but it is what it is and so we
have to celebrate the small wins or we
celebrate the small wins every day so
that mondays don't seem so dark
i'm not gonna i don't know where you've
been but um the subway no i'm kidding no
i mean never i don't
here on the show we really do try and
just help people get through the week
obviously monday can be so monday
but every day has its own personality
and we're always looking for the lead up
to friday and when friday is here we
have to acknowledge that and we have to
just look forward i mean after this
you're going golfing yeah how fabulous
for you yes
it's fabulous for you i'm going to
snuggle up with brew and get ready to
celebrate our anniversary
one year anniversary of brew today
no it's like in a few days i need to get
the exact date but it's end of october
it's close it's close so i've just been
like you know ruminating on life with
brew the last year with brew
and it's just been something so special
i mean i know you don't really know him
i know him as much as i'm allowed to you
know you have to keep him like
uh what is her name rapunzel up in a
tower he's calling for help he's
screaming ben pick me up giacomo let me
leave the bedroom
we've watched shrek 90 times brew love
shrek he loves donkey he thinks he's
hilarious
um by the way you love shrek i mean
shrek is so good yes rex is good it's so
[ __ ] good i just watched all four
recently and the music it's it's just
it's so [ __ ] good so good can be
understated no i just i don't know
why you're kind of like an absent uncle
and you haven't spent that much time
with brad does that even me no i'm
kidding like when you you i guess you
know brew like when you come over from
monopoly he's always there being good
boy i see brew as much as i'm invited to
see brew am i supposed to come over and
pick up brew and take him to the park i
have i have crew i just won you know
like i would do that for theo i did do
that for theo when you didn't have brew
i would still do that for theo you would
randomly walk over to my apartment leave
bruno at home pick up theo and take him
to the park without me asking you if i
could sense that's what theo without me
asking if i could sense it yeah okay
yeah cool well theo right now because
claudia's away is home alone why don't
you bring him in uh because he's
actually out with our walker oh and he's
walking yeah because we're recording a
little early and also you're going off
things
but after this though if you want he's
there alone you could go pick him up
take him to the park walk him around and
then drop them back to the apartment
before you go and hang out with brew
interesting that sounds good definitely
think about that i'll definitely
consider it you could actually take them
to your house
yeah
anyways we have a great show for you
today we actually have so much to
discuss like so much newsie news
and i need to get your take on all of it
there was no tv on last night i
personally spent the evening reading i'm
almost finished with my book i'm reading
apple's never fall by leanne moriarty
now i'm at like 75 so it's like all
downhill from here we're about to get
answers we're about to slide into home
like the majority of the beginning of
the book was just like set up and now
it's payoff time do you ever consider
watching sports
it's just interesting to hear there's
nothing on last night there was so much
on last night oh yeah zach was watching
a game i believe it was the browns
versus the
yeah logo that looked like the bills but
wasn't football's i mean last night's
football was very boring but there was a
warriors game last night stephen curry
okay he had 25 points in the first
quarter
wow he only finished like 45 but i'm
just saying there's some there was some
good stuff on tv okay and i would highly
recommend on thursday nights tuning into
tnt there's an nba double header
riveting in case there's a lack of
television on thursdays okay yeah well
think about it um i'm more of a tmt over
tnt girly that's fair but that's just me
that's fair you need a news network like
a tv news network we got to bring it on
cnn we got to bring it onto tv yeah wow
we're already on tv it depends how you
choose to stream our show but you can
you know get the youtube app and watch
us and i've actually seen
like my favorite thing is getting tagged
in stories when i see people watching
the toast on tv yeah no same it's
amazing it's a premium experience
premium yeah and like the the quality of
the the set the camera lights camera
action like they don't even know that
this couch is busted yeah but you know
we suffer through the couch no it's good
it's good for you yeah you look extra
uncomfortable today no it's it's because
i'm choosing to hike my big tree trunk
leg up yeah
yeah that's a lot of light
i'm looking in the monitor
we're seeing a lot of leg today yeah wow
how fortunate for all of you yeah you
guys you're welcome here you're welcome
so i think we can get right into
everything because there's a lot to
discuss you have you know to go golfing
and we wouldn't want to hold you up you
know sure and i think
you're not holding me up though we we
will take our time we will take our time
we will go through the stories okay that
god intended them to be told you can't
rush the two no especially not these
juicy stories yes so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
beat it you beat the crunch and so you
win a pair of transition lenses
no
but i'm telling you beat the crunch
great app we get at least seven
downloads and 50 grand for development
member of our family
okay before we get into the stories i
need to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own license professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas the
services available for clients worldwide
it's a very accessible way to
get therapy get in touch with someone
you know
it's never too late to ask for help and
better help is a better way to do that
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily visit
betterhelp.com
toast that's betterhelp h-e-l-p and join
the over 2 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp that
they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 15 50 states
so you guys we have a special offer for
the morning toast listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
toast
okay first story this was breaking news
last night i think it's a big story of
the day
alec baldwin fired a prop gun that
killed a cinematographer and injured a
director on this movie on the set of his
new movie rust
cinematographer hal haley na hutchins
was killed and director joel souza was
injured on thursday after alec baldwin
accidentally misfired a prop gun on the
new mexico set of his upcoming western
film authorities responded to the
incident at the bonanza creek ranch set
of rust that's the name of the movie
around 1 50 pm local time following
9-1-1 calls indicating an individual had
been shot on set the spanish bay
sheriff's department wrote in a press
release obtained by people
what was the name of the cinematographer
the
one who passed away
how you know elena
first and foremost
uh
horrendous story horrendous and uh
apologies and justice for the family of
helena because that is like possibly the
worst way to die that i've ever heard
you're on set a movie right and a prop
gun is fired by somebody that shouldn't
have had a real bullet in their gun
like there's no that's not a dangerous
area yeah it's terrible no it's terrible
i mean there are so many
questions about this story why there
wasn't a gun an active gun on the set
whether that what was inside the gun was
it a bullet or a blank but regardless
there are people whose job it is to
manage the props there's a prop master
why is
someone walking around with a gun that
could kill people what do you think
i don't know i don't know enough about
the movie industry or guns to understand
how something like this could happen
i definitely can't imagine one i had no
idea that prop guns could be filled
that seems incredibly strange or i'm
saying like we don't have enough
technology to make a prop gun that
sounds like a gun looks like a gun but
doesn't actually load like a gun or just
have a prop gun and then you add special
effects like we have whole [ __ ]
movies that are made on the computer you
can't just add the sound it has to be
something that shoots out of a canon by
the way i'm positive that because of
this like they won't let guns
they won't let prop guns on sets anymore
you think so yeah this is like a crazy
[ __ ] story
where
there's obviously foul play i don't know
who did it but like by the way we're
turning into this is turning into like a
murder mystery podcast i'm just saying
like there's a couple of between the the
guy in the lake yesterday this one which
that one we can get to um
but either
either alec baldwin and this person
had beef
okay that's like the far-fetched version
okay i don't think that's what it is but
i'm just saying all right so it would
either be alec baldwin put the bullet in
and killed that person i don't think
that's what it is but
because it's a murder mystery podcast we
have to explore all routes okay
uh and then the one that makes the most
sense would be that the prop master
uh had beef with the person or
it was some just horrendous accident
that is unexplained that maybe somebody
on set they said it's in new mexico yeah
are there what are the
gun laws in new mexico i'm unfamiliar
like are you just able to bring a gun
into
a film set because maybe somebody
accidentally put their gun down on the
table
it was mistook for the prop gun
handed to baldwin
pow-pow perhaps i don't know
i don't know about all that i think it
was more so negligence
but
the negligence on who if it's a prop
why was it loaded
i don't know it can't be negligence
you want to move your mic closer i'm
just worried about that
my mic is like in my mouth
it can't be negligence
i hope we get more
details and clarity around this story
because there needs to be
answers here there needs to be
responsibility and
accountability and justice yeah and and
like regardless of if it was alec
baldwin's fault he's
super rich and should definitely take
care of this
person's family like yeah but i mean
there right now there's no charges that
have been filed but
it's just that it's just a human being
normal thing to do yeah accidentally
murdered no of course of course but i'm
just wondering if there's going to be
any legal repercussions like
for sure manslaughter there has to be i
don't know if it's
manslaughter manslaughters
would be
the term
because he did kill someone such a
strange story yeah i i really don't know
what to make of it i read it last night
i get all of my news from like
these like weird instagram accounts that
just like show headlines and then i have
to do my own research because it's like
is it really how hard yeah i got i think
i got it from a hood ratchet tv i think
was my news source yeah um and i was
like what the [ __ ] is that true yeah
yeah no when i saw it i was i was
shocked it sounds like a it's like a
plot for a bad movie yeah or a good
movie like this it actually sounds like
an adam sandler did you see the terrible
movie he made up first of all adam
sandler unbelievable okay until he
signed this deal with netflix
all of these movies murder on the boat
or whatever i like that one it's getting
a sequel oh my god of course he's
getting a sequel he has a minimum amount
of movies he needs to make for his 300
million they're going to sequel all of
these shitty movies do you see who be
halloween no i'm not watching any of it
i'm not watching them i think you should
watch who be halloween is it as good as
mr deeds
no i i wouldn't say that this is it as
good as big daddy no i i wouldn't say is
it as good as billy madison no is it as
good as happy gilmore no good so i'm not
i never said it was good no some oh oh
you were saying it was bad i was saying
it was it was like shocking oh
shockingly bad but it wasn't that it
wasn't good he's so bad it wasn't good
but it wasn't like jack and jill bad i
also want to clarify i would do the same
thing if i was him 300 million for free
no and like the movies that he's even
putting on netflix are like
so successful they're successful because
it's netflix yeah nobody netflix can
make anything it wants successful with
the right name and adam sandler you will
watch his movie but even by netflix's
standards it's successful like they they
do that with a lot of things in a lot of
people but still people have to you know
select to watch it
yeah i guess but what i was saying was
it sounds like the beginning of a murder
on a boat movie by adam sandler
yeah you know it's like that like and
then the whole movie is just like about
what was with the gun
yeah what was with the gun now you want
to make it no i just want the i just
want answers i just want to be you know
um
a reader and i want i hope that
we get some sort of understanding as to
how something like this could happen
because it's
i don't think we will so upsetting by
the way in case uh listeners or watchers
see me go like this
it's just because i'm stretching my
planters
it's it's rather sore so don't be
alarmed if you see me doing this strange
stretch i don't think from time to time
oh you can't even see it okay yeah on
your solo shot and what are your
planters if i may plantar fasciitis is a
bone
that goes under the midsection
of the bottom of the foot
and the heel
um and it's just [ __ ] sore i don't
know i self-diagnose myself but that
stretch really helps
um
yeah that is
that is my medical
uh
explanation of plantar fasciitis okay
thank you for that you learned something
new every day calf stretches are good
for it too
okay get a good like calf board
um
but yeah sweet thank you of course are
you ready for our next story sure
the human remains found in florida park
do belong to brian laundry the fbi
confirms the fbi has confirmed that the
human remains found at a north port
florida park on wednesday belonged to 23
year old brian laundry medical examiners
used a comparison of dental records to
positively identify the remains
the fbi's denver division wrote in a
press release on thursday
so i guess that's that on that
it actually makes the story a little bit
sadder because now it seems like
do you like
actually no it's not sadder well
i'm just saying like he clearly went
there like probably killed himself in
the same place where he either killed
his girlfriend or no these are totally
see i mean different places
she was found in a whole other state got
him okay
and then he went home to florida and
then he found a park near florida got it
so the guy just loves sparks i guess so
i guess parks you know
that is a good point that's that's all i
was just thinking like
maybe like he brought her to the park
something happened in the park then he
went back to the park no no no different
no different park and also i do feel
like he was at a national park with her
this to me is giving me like
you know
playground
vibes even though it's not but like you
know like a smaller local park i
understand not on the national level no
no even though i that's just a feeling
north
yeah just it's parked with a lowercase p
i understand you understand of course i
do so i think yeah like a local park
yeah i have a great name if like the
like cnbc wants to do it it wouldn't be
cnbc who would make like a documentary
about this
what's your name what network a hulu
anyone know what it's called
brian's
dirty laundry
that's pretty good right
that's real
i can't
i can't i don't know that's a great name
here's the thing sometimes with these
stories like you know the
the most obvious answer is the simplest
answer is the the answer
and so i like part of me just wants to
be like okay so case closed and he
probably you know allegedly probably did
kill
gabby and now he's dead too so i guess
that's that on that
but i it it there's still something
that's just like rings suspicious about
all this but maybe that's just like our
nature to like want there to be
you know a twist like in movies but this
isn't a movie i mean when people are
found dead in water in parks it's weird
yeah it's not like a
it's not normal life
they write movies about weird ass things
like this the
the remains that were like sampled were
his dental remains like
even though this is really far-fetched
like he could have pulled out some teeth
left you know or nah they probably got a
whole thing like a could have taken out
his whole jaw
no i don't think he did that i don't
know i just like but i don't really i
don't want to you know
gravitate towards like making this like
a movie and you know it's disrespectful
to like the whole situation so
i understand
i hope
okay you know
i hope that justice will be served
it can't be i know there's no justice no
it's bizarre it is it's just a weird
story it is back-to-back
weird stories yes
but we're going to get into our next
story a little bit of not not news
that's much better but a little bit and
i just want to let you know it's brought
to you by one of us is lying which is
peacock's new show
five students walk into detention and
only four walk out alive follow the
story based on the number one new york
times best seller one of us is lying now
a new peacock original on the first day
of school yell set bronwyn baseball star
cooper cheerleader addie and drug
dealing nate all land themselves in
detention with notorious gossip blogger
simon when one of them doesn't make it
out alive everyone becomes a suspect
each with their own secrets and motives
this juicy teen drama takes unexpected
new twists as we find out who's hiding
what in this can't miss new series with
romance betrayal secrecy and more one of
us is lying is the murder mystery of the
season so don't miss one of us is lying
streaming now only on peacock go to
peacock peacocktv.com to get started
doesn't that sound like a great show i
love a jtd
a jtd a juicy teen drama oh what's
better i mean after dale by the way the
show that just never should have ended
after now yes we need to bring back
after dale because there are still three
people out there who would love to watch
yeah and i'm sure that those three are v
those three are incredibly important
yeah i know and they feel alone they
feel deserted we need to bring back
after dale for them is riverdale still
running yeah it is the new season just
came out he could have been stars by now
with afterdale i'm just saying big stars
could have been picked up hulu
hulu our next story queen elizabeth
spends the night in the hospital for
tests after canceling her trip the queen
spent the night in the hospital for
tests after canceling official duties
royal doctors sent the 95 year old
sovereign to be seen by specialists in
london on wednesday afternoon her
majesty was discharged with buckingham
palace saying she was in good spirits
after preliminary investigations during
her visit to the hospital it was
believed her medical team acted out of
caution to have her admitted on
wednesday and the overnight stay her
first in a hospital in eight years was
for practical reasons yesterday it was
understood that her majesty was back at
her desk at windsor castle
so
obviously you'd never want to see a
headline that the queen is in the
hospital no and for us queenie files
like
this is just
it's worrisome
it's it's also just like
how much does it suck to be the queen
that you can't even go to the hospital
without it being news yeah like you know
like
how like i get why it's news i'm just
saying like you leave like imagine you
go to the hospital somebody writes it up
that stinks
yeah all but the only thing is the only
difference between myself and the queen
is that she has like so many resources
at her disposal in her own home i was
thinking the same that
it does sort of raise
alarms when she has to go to the
hospital for something
i i totally understand and i agree
i was just saying like even if it is
very juicy it's just like yeah no but
just people are worried about her people
i was gonna say exactly what you just
said which is that she obviously has an
in-home doctor yeah so you would only go
to the hospital
if you needed something checked that
they couldn't check there
perhaps it's
uh
like a machine that's just you know not
something that you yeah i'm trying to
think like what that could be
neurology related perhaps
maybe something with like i don't know
we don't have the guests or diseases we
don't have nobody no no we don't need to
guess her disease we don't need to guess
what happened i just i'm glad to hear
that she's doing okay i hope she's doing
well you know
prayer is up for the queen prayer's up
for the queen i love her yes i mean
she's great she's great she's cool yeah
she is so
thinking of you queenie take some time r
and r just what the doctor ordered yes
maybe a visit to sandringham i think she
needs some fresh air yep
that's the prescription maybe uh she
should watch it tjd
she should watch a juicy teen drama how
about jtd that'll help her in her
hospital style one of us is lying on
peacock that's what the queen should be
watching
i do wonder what she binge watches the
crown
probably by the way
if she watches the crown she probably
loves it it really doesn't rip her no it
doesn't it rips the people around her
and that is why first of all gary
gianetti love him genius
the show like i get it like why are you
making fun of a six-year-old but like
we're that's the prince what did i say
we're talking about the crown oh i've
never seen the crowd no the prince rips
queen it does yeah really yeah the
prince rips everyone really yeah but it
mostly rips the people around her
i've never seen her but also i only
watch satire i've never seen the crown
no
but i've seen downton abbey isn't it the
same thing um it's similar
but you should watch the crown is it
good it's really good so i'll tell you
uh i've probably seen half an episode of
the crown claudia likes to do this where
we start a show together yes and then i
have to go to work and she finishes it
we know all about it so we all agree
with her that she should keep watching
no i get it but i have zero opportunity
to watch a full show because i'm never
gonna watch a show without her i don't
like wanna
finish my day and then sit in the other
room and watch tv alone like i wanna sit
with her and watch tv so we have to pick
a show together that's why i miss the
old days of weekly nightly releases
weekly at night releases we're having
such a great time with impeachment
because we binged it together on a
sunday and now episodes air every
tuesday at eight
so we huddle together
light a candle order a little grand
szechuan
watch impeachment that's beautiful it is
i'm sorry that it doesn't happen more
often for you that's okay do you know
that uh
when you guys oh i guess it's only
claudia i was gonna say the when she
orders seamless it comes up that jackie
and claudia have ordered seamless and it
texts my phone so no matter where i am i
know when you guys are ordering food or
i guess it's her only yeah your name's
on my seamless that's so funny that's
like but i'm not getting the food were
you using it and ordering no not that
i'm aware of that's really random sounds
like you've hacked my seamless i have
not
i have not okay ready for our next story
of course some happy couple news real
housewives of new jersey star teresa
giudice is engaged to her boyfriend luis
relas she shared photos with
people magazine and they're so cute and
fabulous
oh yes
she said um
the he popped the question in greece
incorporating sparklers candles roses
violinists and fireworks
into his proposal that's pretty that's
pretty lavish the pictures are really
cute i'm really happy for teresa
obviously you know the journey that
she's been on yes and she's been dating
luis for probably over a year now but we
still never even we didn't see him on
last season of real housewives of new
jersey we heard about him and then he
showed up at the reunion so i'm assuming
he'll be much more involved in this
upcoming season and we can get a sense
of like
how their relationship is you know
because we don't really know them
together but she seems really happy and
i'm glad that she's you know
found love
i like the real housewives of new jersey
yeah they're all very nice ladies they
really are i actually i met uh
melissa gorga for the first time at a
spritz party i know and she was
incredibly lovely incredibly nice i've
met margaret joseph and her husband
several times lovely amazing i've never
met theresa but i'm sure she's lovely
too it's just funny like they're so nice
and like on the show they're made to be
like these crazy people and it's like
they're just nice people no they are
just nice people and i do think you know
the cameras go up and it's a job and
totally and i get why yeah i mean
totally like anything that's like in
real life you would just like brush off
your shoulder you need to address and
rehash and then the next time we see
each other are we over it no let's talk
about it again and you have to just like
bring the action
that's like a it just said will i am go
through
reaction as i said
that was so weird it was like him in my
head bringing the action
um but uh
yeah like if people aren't drinking you
gotta just like start ripping shots like
you gotta you gotta
bring the action yeah you do have to get
it but yeah they're super nice yeah so
we're happy for theresa yeah happy from
theresa i wonder if she'll get a
spin-off of her wedding bravo used to do
that a lot especially for like the og's
you know tamra had one
kim zolciak bethany i feel like they'll
definitely do it for anyone
that will let them well theresa would
definitely let them so then i think that
they'll do it you know what i mean like
i think that it's amazing content for
them
uh
just not everybody wants their wedding
day
completely kerfuffled with cameras well
i don't know i mean i i think teresa
definitely would she's been on tv for
like 10 years i think that would be a
no-brainer for her i just wonder if
there's enough interest like from the
viewers because i do think that's waning
i don't know how those specials perform
interesting because there's been a while
since we've had one i have to imagine
it's for a reason well maybe they don't
have to draw it out out like for like
four episodes like just give give us
like a one episode teresa gets married
yeah like it's turning into like even
when cynthia bailey got married like it
was like
five minutes in a real housewives of
atlanta episode but there's also because
i don't think they could have cameras in
because it was like a coveted wedding
but it was big weddings
yeah
we shall see we shall see and we're
happy for teresa and that's just some
exciting news i guess real housewives of
new jersey will be premiering soon i
mean the real housewives have really
been in the news this week because of
that book i don't know you probably
haven't heard about it there's a new
book that just
dropped it's called not all diamonds and
rose and it's like an oral history of
the real housewives and it's by like
andy cohen books so it's
you know bravo endorsed and all the
women were out promoting it i think the
premiere the launch party was in the
city the other night and so there's just
like every day there's new headlines
about like things that are coming out of
the book and i'm not gonna lie it is
it is pushing me towards reconsidering
reading it i still haven't decided to
read it but i'm more interested than i
once was
so
claudia loves every book written by andy
cohen so if it's written by him it's not
it's just endorsed by him oh interesting
yeah they both decided we weren't going
to read it but they're doing a good job
on the press i'm i'm
considering it i'm considering it yeah
so we shall see but if the real
housewives of new york asked you to be
on the show as a real housewife what
would you say
probably not
really yeah
i think considering i thought you were
gonna say that but i'm fairly certain
you would say yes i would consider it
you know i'd be a fool not to but when
it came down to it i just couldn't
see i don't see it happening but i would
consider it
yeah
but you just got to put things out in
the air if you want them to happen so
yes putting it out there but if you want
it to happen i think you do
i don't know
i like this show i'm good with this and
also like how would i do this show
if
easily
and then they would also promote the
show on bravo they'd literally be back
there filming this yeah the thing is i
don't think they're i don't think this
is gonna be something i have to struggle
with anytime soon i don't think they're
asking
we shall see and that's okay with me i
understand
okay let's get into our fifth and final
story before we do i must let you know
it is brought to you by current current
is a technology company that lets you
manage your money on your phone current
believes banking should be more
accessible and affordable no surprises
no minimum balances current's easy to
use app and debit card gives you
flexibility freedom and faster access to
your money with benefits like earning
points when you swipe with your debit
card at eligible merchants redeemable
for cash back no fees on over 40 000
in-network all-point atms in the u.s
helpful spending insights and
notifications to track where and when
you're spending easy to create savings
goals including the ability to round up
purchases to save extra charge so for a
limited time we've partnered with
current to give away one thousand
dollars that's right current is going to
give away 250 dollars to four listeners
of our show all you have to do is
download the current app and enter our
code toast during sign up for a chance
to win that's toast during sign up
winners will be awarded soon so don't
wait download the current app sign up in
less than two minutes and enter code
toast for a chance to win visit
current.com
toast for full terms and conditions
exciting
okay our fifth and final story and you
know we absolutely must serenade because
i can't do it again though no but could
you give us a different version maybe i
had seen a request for a euphagenia
version that's
singing in euphoria i don't know if i
could if anyone could we'll see
something will happen i don't know
what's gonna happen though
first what it's the final story
[Music]
to do
i couldn't possibly
no i can't i started too high yifijanai
has left the chat yeah she's left she's
left maybe monday but
no i can't today okay
you can think about for monday what you
want to do for your final final story i
think it's like i'm i'm even thinking
how i could do that it's
doo doo doo
[Music]
the voice for the next one on monday
okay
the whoever whatever they pick that's
what you'll do that's what i'll do it's
hard to what are their what are their
options i think it needs to be more of
like the first one was cantorial which i
can do i can also do opera
okay
opera rock punk like pick a genre okay
we'll try and do that okay cool that's
exciting so we have that to look forward
to on monday even though you know it
will be monday we'll have that we'll
have a great monday
our fifth and final story is actually a
really cute um
piece of news zach galvinakis says that
his sons don't know he's an actor he
said my kids think i'm a librarian how
old are they by the way
uh four and seven cute he may have two
emmy wins and plenty of hit films but to
his children he's simply their dad and
possibly a librarian
the comedian told entertainment tonight
at the premiere of his new movie ron's
gone wrong that his kids don't know he's
a popular actor he said my kids think
i'm a librarian somewhere they don't
even know they think i'm a nice they
think i'm an assistant librarian
somewhere
he said his children aren't familiar
with one of his most favorite famous
works the hangover when asked by
entertainment tonight if his children
have seen the movie he said they shall
never know of it he added i'll just deny
it i'll say i don't know what you're
talking about i had nothing to do with
that movie well he'll eventually get to
the point of showing his children the
film he's avoiding the tricky situation
for the time being the actor explained
you want to protect their innocence as
much as possible they're just children
it's so crazy i guess like when you look
at the hangover through the lens of a
four-year-old you're like that's
inappropriate but when i think of
inappropriate movies like um the
hangover is just a movie to me totally
but at four and at seven you can't see
that movie yeah you also can't see your
dad like doing drugs in that yeah like
that's the first of all zach
galifianakis love him so funny so
between two ferns have you seen it
it's just like he is
not only underappreciated but i think
he's underappreciated because he really
per that story seems to really not want
to be in the limelight unless he's doing
something yeah he's all about the craft
yeah all about the craft he is
hysterical
um i love that his kids think that he's
a librarian
and
yeah just that's a great story yeah and
that's a great like fake
job to share with your kids that you are
you know and also that might encourage
them to read more and you know i think
that's that's beautiful it's beautiful
maybe i'll tell my kids i'm a librarian
yeah they'll never know about the toast
yeah interesting
i'm sure that they will know about the
toast i'm sure that they will mm-hmm
they could watch the toast from any age
that's the best part about this show i
mean we do use a little bit of profanity
like curse words profanity is not the
problem i remember i was five years old
i had a sleepover at some kid's house
okay
mom decided to show us the terminator i
had nightmares for weeks is that a scary
movie it wasn't even scary it's just
like rated r and then it's just like
it was a little scary it was a little
scary for me i really was like a big
just like frady cat my mom never let me
even see pg-13 movies yeah i just like
was a big pg guy yeah i really stuck to
what the like
i was watching g then i was watching pg
then i turned 13. you know like and then
me too like
those rules are in place for a reason i
think they're really good markers of age
but did you ever i used to think that if
i watched a rated r movie i'd go to jail
like i mean like that somebody would
come to my house find me watching a
rated r movie and throw me in prison no
the idea of watching a rated r movie
like at home at home before it was like
not going to happen but i remember like
you know when i was in high school
before i turned 17 because you have to
be 17 seventeen point trade star right
that's called nc seventeen uh that's
before you can watch porn no like no
i know there's energy so it's 16 before
you started watching porn what's rated r
rated r i think is rated rh because when
i would go to the movies 16 no 16 rated
r age limit because when i would go to
the movies and to see a rated r movie oh
i forgot you had to show your ideas show
your student id 17. okay
i'm not a [ __ ] pervert did you ever
go to the lowe's orpheum
to watch a movie at 86th street and what
there's like 56th and third yeah that's
the big one yeah with the old man yes oh
my god that he was taking no prisoners
no he literally would put your id
through a scandrum like you're at a club
to go into the rated r movie and it's
like you're 17 so it's just your student
id yeah what are you supposed to do he
literally would
it was he was not messing around i was
not messing around he was not gonna if
you were not 17 like you were not seeing
that tell me no you were not even if you
were sometimes you'd be turned away yeah
it's because you thought it was fake how
do you say that a student id is fake i
mean it's probably extremely easy to
face it's full-blown plastic though like
how do you prove that it's fake or not
fake yeah no there's no tech in the
student id i'm sure at that location he
was used to seeing the same schools you
know whatever schools are in the
neighborhood but you could also just say
you know i'm out of town i'm from out of
town here's i can't see this film here's
my kansas student id yeah what's wrong
with that kid kid from kansas can't come
to the orpheum not if that guy's working
there no i i'm positive he's still there
also i just feel like he's gonna be
there for like 200 years i actually just
passed that movie theater the other day
and
i was thinking about all those times
isn't it crazy to think how
lit those two blocks were
like now it's just decrepid and like
times have changed but you know it was
like from pinkberry up from pinkbed well
that's on second yeah yeah well
pinkberry up was great but 86th street
86 second and third was one movie
theater 86 87th and lex was another
movie theater there was the best spy
there was a game stop oh well you're
like a boy so those things weren't
working area was just wonderful i was
more there for the pink fairy
interesting
i mean pinkberry was still i eat
pinkberry all the time yeah i haven't
had in a while but it's still it still
hits it definitely had a bit of a fall
from grace from i don't know but why
though it's a great place well i don't
think it should have ever been as hyped
up as it was fair and so of course
nothing is that sustainable like
remember crumbs
yeah but big [ __ ] yeah but i was
never into it cupcakes i i can't get
excited about like to me crumbs is a
better idea than pinkberry i guess
they're out of business yeah well they
went to too too hard too hard too hard
in the paint too hard to pass one place
though that remind pinkberry reminds me
of that also went a little too hard too
fast but i think is
creme de la creme jamba juice do you
ever have jamaica i've never had jamba
juice oh amazing amazing smoothies
really yeah and they just went a little
i think
too hard too fast you know you see
people are coming in loving your stuff
start raising money dump in stores
stores don't do well all of a sudden
you're in one airport in san francisco
yeah
interesting i would never realize
cautionary tale a cautionary tale that's
that's for sure
cool so that's just a little business
lesson for you guys today um what were
we talking about before movies i don't
know oh well it's at galvanocus and
hangover being inappropriate for
children yeah which uh
which it is
yeah which it is but uh
but you know it's not the library true
true
go to the library that's what you guys
should do this week pick out a book
become a redhead have you been to uh the
new york public library i don't think so
interesting have you well you grew up
i've been to the new york public library
i haven't been recently but i will say i
first of all love the idea of a library
and i think the new york public library
is a wonderful place i don't really know
why people need to sit in starbucks and
do work like i'm trying to sit there and
eat uh
an egg sandwich and drink a cup of
coffee are you talking about like
starbucks period all over i'm saying in
general stop taking tables to do work
when you're there to drink coffee and
eat food okay
go to the library you want to do work
there's a library that's a good point
that's all i'm trying to say i guarantee
if you go to the library right now it's
really not that packed does the library
have free wi-fi of course set that up i
don't work for the library yeah but i
have to assume that the library doesn't
charge you for wi-fi
yeah
if they want to stay competitive take
somebody's hot spot
yeah you ever do that
i thought no i don't i've never taken
somebody's hot spot pretty cool that's
you know there's only so much to go
around no it's weird
and plus you usually need a password
yeah
right
i don't know
we're rambling yeah you're rambling yeah
this is who am i yeah cool i don't know
yeah
um okay so that is our show but before
we let you guys go
ben and i do want to do a toast content
of the weekend oh yes so that we have
something to really pour over on monday
and you know we can get our take see if
we land on the same side of the coin
yeah or what the thing is we don't know
what it's going to be yet we've been
thinking i mean we have two very
different ideas of what this concept is
going to look like for me i'm thinking
like topical you know movie of the
moment let's discuss ben wants to watch
a classic i just want you to watch a
movie that i don't think that you've
seen that i think is funny
okay but you were suggesting missed out
fire i didn't know if you'd seen it i
have seen it 1 000 times have you seen
hook
hook what's that where robin williams
oh
like peter pan
um we don't need to watch it probably
not i don't think that no i don't think
i've seen that at least not any time
recently we could watch hook but it's
not his best
it's not his best okay so what else do
you propose i don't know
i'm looking on the streaming services
now
the great british baking show you ever
watch
i started it and i didn't like the vibe
the vibe is everything yeah i just it
just i
i don't know the vibe is why we watch
man i just it just seemed weird
it was weird okay i didn't like it i
mean to each any marvel movies like any
superhero movies have you seen any i've
seen aquaman have you seen the batman
trilogy no
and i'm not going to what is with you
and claudia with being anti-superhero
movies should we watch the new season of
riverdale
we can should watch the new james bond
want to go to the theater oh we could do
that
i'm good though okay what about we could
or we couldn't like we could we could we
could
we could i don't want to
what about um
[ __ ] what was i just gonna say i was
just on my thing oh what about one of us
is lying on peacock
oh is that the show that uh that we just
talked about yeah but did you see teen
drama no i want to watch a juicy teen
drama but what are we gonna do watch one
episode i'm not i i don't have 10 hours
this weekend oh i have two hours okay so
you want like a documentary i want to i
want a movie a documentary
yeah a movie there's a new documentary
about brittany murphy that's out i'm
sure on hbo max
is it getting good reviews like if i'm
going to watch a documentary i think i
think there's a lot especially because i
i think i really i love brittany murphy
okay
i think that that's the one because it's
topical and i think there's a lot of
information there that we don't know
okay and it's celebrity oriented which
is what the show is so we are watching
the brittany murphy documentary on hbo
max please watch along with us and we
will all share our thoughts on monday we
all have a lot to say
so i will now let you go to your golf
expedition thank you so much for thank
you for having me day two of one john
the toast
and we will see you guys on monday i
hope everyone has a great weekend stay
safe out there make sure you're loading
up on
spritzsociety.com you could use code
toast thank you for listening to morning
toast the millennium morning show where
we deliver the past five stories every
day
and yada yada if you've made it this far
into the episode you are now a member of
the society season two please leave an
emoji of
what did we talk about glasses
of wine glasses in commemoration of
spritz society have an amazing weekend
everyone bye have a great weekend